[Music]
super villains
[Music]
sad souls and costumes wanting you to
think they're all
dark and deep what's it like
living life is the punchline
[Music]
but all overtake would be one blessed
act of rebellion
for you to restore your dignity in its
entirety
you know the deal complete the mission
you get 10 years off your sentence
you fail to follow my orders in any way
and i detonate the explosive device in
the base of your skull
love him or hate him these are your
brothers and sisters for the next few
days
any questions and yes that is your hand
very good we're all gonna die
i hope so oh for god's sake
[Music]
this is suicide well that's kind of our
thing
[Music]
like a bloodbath to start the day
they call you peacemaker
i cherish peace with all my heart i
don't care many men women and children i
need to kill to get it
i thought you were crazy oh yeah
wow
here's the deal we fail admission you
die we find out any information you give
us is false
you die if we find out you have
personalized license plates
you die what no
[Music]
foreign